hey guys how's it going Justine here no
I was super excited to film this video
because I had big plans I wanted to be
so decked out in Star Wars but the
costume that I ended up getting ended up
being a child's costume and it did not
fit at all but I did get a few super
cute cautions for my dog but here's the
problem
he doesn't like things on his body
sweaters costumes shirts harnesses he's
not into it I try
[Music]
so the other day in the video I asked
you guys what games I should play on my
phone and I got so many suggestions that
it was by far extremely overwhelming so
I plan on doing some playthroughs of
some other games that you guys suggested
one game stood out in particular EA
dropped me a note and said hey we've got
a game with some exclusive Android only
content that's called Star Wars Galaxies
of heroes and now since like I feel like
I'm a part of the Android family like a
little bit I think you guys have
accepted me just maybe like one foot in
just one foot maybe the other one you
know would was just just testing the
waters a little bit until December 16th
Android users can get K 2 SL from the
new movie for free as a playable
character along with some other valuable
limited time content so I've been
playing this game for the past
I like week and a half I've been so sick
so I'm finally just getting over my cold
which is actually perfect timing because
I spent a lot of time playing this game
and just watching TV so I'm gonna do a
little playthrough for you guys and show
you some of my fun little characters
that I've got I also put a link in the
description if you guys want to download
this and I'm pretty excited because I
really like the recording app that
Google has on here I basically can just
hit record I can screen cap and I can do
a little picture my face just like this
where's the good place to put myself
let's see if I'm looking around like
this I guess I'll just be right here
right that's good I'll stick myself here
so here's like all of the things you can
do I haven't even unlocked everything
yet but I did just recently unlock the
Dark Side battles let's go ahead and
show you some of my characters that I've
got this is cool look at my back oh man
I'm rollin to the screen rewarding so it
looks like my highest level is the Clone
Wars Chewbacca I can train him so let's
train him up son unloose train there you
go little guy okay chew on my sweet
sweet chewy so let's just go through I
will show you guys also something that's
pretty awesome so they have a bunch of
exclusive road 1 content I already
bought a bunch of them so one of the
cool ones that you guys can get which I
was so excited about what I did get I
got the k2s oh he has already leveled up
to level 11 he's so cool like oh I got
to show you guys in hit
all the data cards are where you get
your different characters so let's see I
can what can i buy I spend all my money
okay I got to buy some crystals see I
want to buy the rogue one characters
let's see who we get so kind of
randomizes so depending upon which cards
you get which pack just a lot of money
rebel Pathfinder okay oh and a short
trooper so you have to collect each of
these shards that helps you level up
which of your characters so let's go we
need to do a battle I'm gonna do a light
side battle for you I have to go back
and beat all of these in hard so that I
can earn shards from them
I'll just battle here I'm gonna clear my
squad and I'm gonna go through and pick
who I want all right so we're definitely
gonna do shooing and of course we're
gonna win our girl princess leia k2i so
i love you so much you're so cool you're
so cool so this one's always weak so so
sad if I choose this everybody attacks
Chewbacca whenever you use that one and
it's so sad it's like buddy leave him
alone
how to move myself out of the way can't
us I was so qui so cute I wanted to be
my friend
yes success final one count the baby
there's also thing too if you just push
Auto and it'll heavy employer basically
I much prefer pushing the buttons
because it makes me feel way more
accomplished tendencies it's light for
me victory it is ours
shall we play darkside battle maybe
great squad picks let's go
these guys are so low level right now
because I spent so much time building
these guys up it's gonna take me no time
to fly through this in my no time I mean
it's probably gonna be a few hours but I
can't wait
[Applause]
[Music]
beautiful just beautiful let's see what
else we can do here we've got some
events Oh player 20 Emily 1115 I feel
like this game is super expansive
because there's so many things that I
can do it I'm only level 15 but this
unlocks level 50 they're still so maybe
getting build a guild level 22 look at
this two ships oh my gosh I can complete
fully commander training up a level 60
almost there I just need to play a
little bit longer that's to a challenge
let's go guys
the time is now the time is now things
were happening don't fix my hair was
this victory baby victory is ours
well thank you guys so much for watching
I hope you joined this fun little
playthrough of Star Wars Galaxies of
Heroes if you guys end up playing this
game let me know what you guys think and
if you have any other fun game
suggestions feel free to leave those in
the comments below if you guys have
already seen rogue one no spoilers in
the comments please because I don't
think I can even handle it I'll see you
guys later
[Music]
Oh